bella thorne puts her nipple piercing on
full display in a see-through shirt what
[Music]
the 19 year old actress left the
peppermint Club in West Hollywood Friday
night rocking a sheer top with no bra
the look left absolutely nothing to the
imagination
putting her nipple piercings on full
display what are we wearing the former
Disney darling paired the daring top
with a pair of black silky track pants
and a septum ring it's too much but it
seems the skin baring moment wasn't
totally intentional Bella weighed in
tweeting when you didn't know how
see-through your top was till flash hits
it oops the famous and love star was
recently spotted in can getting close
and personal with Kourtney Kardashian's
ex Scott Disick but she quickly set the
record straight tweeting I'm not talking
to Scott or anyone else but soon after
she was spotted hanging out with her ex
Gregg Sulkin
she even wished him a happy birthday on
Instagram with this sexy shot writing I
love you glad we are here through thick
and thin
[Music]